hi in this video we are going to talk
about variables in code now variables
just like in algebra is when you have a
letter or a name or a word or something
and that represents something else so
here we're gonna say there x equals
Breanna which is a string you can tell
us it has letters and as in quotations
ver x equals Breanna so if we reference
X later on it's gonna know that means
Breanna so if we console.log X without
would print was just breathe but there
is something to be careful about here if
you put console.log X in the quotation
mark that's gonna read that as another
string and just print the letter X so
this is a really simple example but when
I want you to take away from this video
is variables exist in code and you can
store simple things like a string all
the way up to more complicated things
like a function just with a simple name
alright here we have the console up
again let's just show some examples of
variables in code so we're gonna say ver
x equals Breanna
you'll notice some you know JavaScript
syntax that you like to know more later
we'll say ver y equals cheese and if we
decide to go console.log and then here
we say X Y what you think about what you
think that's gonna say what you think
that's gonna look like down here
remember it's not gonna be in here like
we do the bonfire just gonna be down
here just says Breanna cheese very good
because we had x and y Breanna and
cheese but we can add some more things
in here if we want to console.log a
string do likes and then we separate it
with commas let's see if that does this
is Breanna likes cheese very good now
again remember you can have the strings
you can have the boolean's which are
true/false or you can have just numbers
really remember this lesson is all about
the variables we can change up here we
can say Chris if we change that you
think it's gonna continue to console Bri
on it nope it knows it references back
up and knows that X now equals Chris so
it says Chris
likes cheese